no
[Música]
en el preciso momento que abrimos los
ojos esta mañana cosas mágicas que
ocurrieron dentro de nuestro cerebro
millones de estímulos llegaron a
billones de neuronas estableciendo
innumerables conexiones entre ellas la
sinapsis que hace posible nuestro
aprendizaje un hablaré de neurociencia
pero si una parte del aprendizaje que
conlleva un proceso inverso
desprendernos de algunas de las
colecciones que hemos establecido en el
pasado para construir un futuro de
aprendizaje continuo hoy voy a hablarles
la importancia de desprendernos para
aprender
a albert einstein uno de los científicos
más influyentes del siglo 20 le tomó 15
años aprender sobre cosmología moderna
para esa época diversos científicos
habían descubierto teorías que
contradecía en las de einstein pero él
se resistía a cuestionar las subidas
recientes investigaciones cuentan que él
sin solo aductor nuevos conocimientos
cuando de manera intencional dejó parte
de su red cercana para frecuentar una
red más amplia de científicos aprendió
cuando se desprendió
una suposición común es que aprender
significa adquirir algo nuevo parece el
acto de ganar atraer y sumar
conocimiento pero si navegamos profundo
lo que implica aprender nos damos cuenta
que también consiste en abandonar un
conjunto de ideas situaciones y personas
que nutren lo que hoy somos y conocemos
no existe aprendizaje sin
desprendimiento
pero qué extraña sabrá hablar del
desprendimiento ese sentimiento de
pérdida voluntaria e intencional como
parte esencial de nuestro aprendizaje lo
común es reconocer al orador da vinci
por la gioconda pero desconocer que
también fue ingeniero militar por 12
años tiempo que fue clave en su proceso
creativo y pudo dar los primeros trazos
a la mona lisa o pensar el anita roddick
como una exitosa empresaria con cientos
de tiendas de productos sostenibles
alrededor del mundo dar brillo pero
desconocer que primero fue activista a
favor de culturas originarias en asia y
áfrica lo que inspiró su compromiso pero
el consumo responsable
esa oportunidad que toman algunas
personas de desprenderse de lo que son
hoy para adoptar nuevos caminos resulta
fundamental pero no son el tipo de
información que encontramos en las hojas
de vida ni los perfiles del inti
por años el mundo del trabajo nos ha
impulsado a creer que el aprendizaje es
necesariamente un proceso lineal
que los caminos claros enfocados
rebosantes de consistencia son los
caminos del éxito quizás por eso algunos
hemos caído en la tentación de querer
ser historias fáciles de comprar
pero sobre los caminos sinuosos esos que
cambian mucho que avanzan retroceden que
están repletos de desprendimientos son
en esos caminos donde podemos encontrar
un poco de los da vinci roddick y demás
genialidades que habitan en nuestra
mente
militen dice que soy emprendedora en
serie estratégica forma de explicar que
no he pasado más de tres años en el
mismo rol o trabajo y aunque sí me
considero emprendedora con el tiempo he
aprendido a valorar más desprendimiento
aquellos que al inicio me hacen sentir
un poco incómoda o perdida pero que han
sido una fuente importante de impacto y
aprendizaje continuo
cuando fue la última vez que te
desprendes te de una idea que tenías muy
arreglada
en el 2014 dejé mi trabajo como
funcionaría en el estado para emprender
junto a 8 extraordinarios amigos una una
plataforma que conecta e impulsa a más
de 300 emprendedores a lo largo de todo
un país
pasará el sector estatal al sector
emprendedor implicó en donar parte de mi
sesgada forma de ver el mundo para
abrazar nuevas mentalidades por ejemplo
que el bienestar social de un país no
sólo necesita buenos funcionarios
públicos sino de todo un ecosistema que
permita que entidades del estado
universidades empresas y otros actores
articulan esfuerzos hoy una joven
importante papel como bisagra de
iniciativas públicas y privadas
generando un impacto positiva en la vida
de miles de personas
pero qué importante es también
desprendernos de las ideas que limitan
nuestro potencial
desde que trabajes tienes en 2017 quedé
fascinada por el rápido desarrollo y
adopción de tecnología casi
inmediatamente le puse aprender piper un
lenguaje de programación y dos años
después me asomé a un increíble equipo
de ingenieros y científicos de data para
lanzar beat beat technology una startup
que desarrolla inteligencia artificial
para minería
entrar al mundo del desarrollo
tecnológico implicó que me cuestionar a
si quería seguir creciendo alrededor de
mis fortalezas o superar todo aquello
que limitaba mi potencial y es que hay
que decirlo en el colegio yo no fui la
mejor alumna en matemática de hecho fue
el único curso que pasé con la nota
mínima por eso por años creí que el
mundo de las ciencias de la tecnología
de la ingeniería el mundo stem no era
para mí
sin embargo seguirá en rumbo de mi
curiosidad me invitó a redescubrir mi
pasión por las matemáticas y el sector
digital
ahora desde deep y technology
contribuimos a despertar el interés de
más jóvenes por convertirse en líderes
tecnológicos que impulsen el desarrollo
de latinoamérica
finalmente que están dispuestos estamos
a desprendernos de la comodidad es sólo
frecuentar personas que piensan y
sienten igual que nosotros
por siete años tuve el privilegio de
organizar el encuentro de líderes
universitarios más importantes del perú
cada que cada año reúne a 600 jóvenes
provenientes de todas las regiones del
país y de distintas profesiones
uno de los momentos más memorables era
cuando los 600 participantes nos
dividimos en 30 grupos para diseñar
soluciones innovadoras
era increíble la cantidad de ideas
disruptivas que surgían pero más
increíble era la cohesión que
seiscientos extraños podíamos construir
en tan solo cuatro días
conectar con personas que tienen
perspectivas y experiencias de vida tan
distintas a las mías me mostró que la
diversidad es la fuente más poderosa de
aprendizaje
pero paradójicamente parece ser que la
universidad es el aprendizaje más
difícil de construir
en los últimos cinco años he acompañado
a empresas y a personas a repensar sus
culturas de aprendizaje basadas en
diversidad equidad e inclusión
en estas experiencias no dejo de
sorprenderme como la infinita
plasticidad de nuestras mentes se puede
ver opacada por los sesgos y
estereotipos que construimos alrededor
de las personas y situaciones que
tenemos
lo que tanja un caimán define como
sesgos cognitivos la flojera de nuestros
cerebros que nos lleva a convertir esas
primeras percepciones o emociones que
tenemos cuando conocemos a alguien por
primera vez en conjeturas muy profundas
y difíciles de cuestionar
cada vez que nos negamos a desprendernos
de los prejuicios que tenemos estamos
perdiendo innumerables oportunidades de
crecimiento
de esas reflexiones en el 2017 en acción
just a una startup de educación y
tecnología que crea experiencias de
aprendizaje disruptivas para mujeres
profesionales que buscamos construir
carreras tan exitosas como auténticas
y esta fue fundada por cuatro mujeres
que honramos la diversidad no sólo de
personas sino de historias y desde donde
queremos inspirar un movimiento que
repiense el mundo del trabajo para
hacerlo más diverso más equitativo y más
inclusión
pero dejar atrás nuestra percepción del
mundo de nosotros mismos y las personas
que nos rodean no es un proceso natural
desde la ciencia el comportamiento
sabemos que nuestros cerebros tienden a
buscar lo familiar lo que es como lo que
ya conocemos
por eso esta es una invitación a tomar
el timón de nuestro aprendizaje y
permitirnos navegar la incomodidad la
humildad y el coraje que implica
desprendernos para aprender
entonces tú de que te vas a desprender
hoy
[Música]